welcome to this video I'm playing
chromos from from from from Norway right
yeah I was a forum or we confused them
with Iceland but this is really
different ok we have a chick or any type
of position where I always play this
lame setup I really should should should
study this and try to punish people a
bit for the same no not that the chi
Goran is totally bad but this is really
too little yeah ok
it's probably going to play five some
somewhere so I want to make some
pressure here at the center maybe take
on d 50 is still going for this
interesting okay young knight takes and
maybe have a 45 at least for some for
some imbalance if she takes with the
Queen however
yeah that's really less than nothing
whoops you for something like that I
don't know I can take out three him like
a tape with the jeep on I'm i have a
very irritating little big fly in my
room just like that I opened the window
maybe inside going out and let's see him
let's see and don't really have a good
move here
ah this was really bad yeah what what
did i do him maybe I can take here 95 95
yeah this is in fact sir okay help right
still okay
and I i think i got rid of the floor no
i didn't this is really irritating okay
well i'm attacking the rook and the
Queen here so probably will have some
trades I can take on these seven first
and I will this is actually quite
comfortable I think with the bishop
against against the night yeah now this
is this is a bit better provider because
of the superior minor piece enter d file
let's see with rook always is offering a
rook trade well I can actually take it
again take the default rock the eight
Bishop f5 loses instantly so I think it
should be very nice yeah Bishop b4 yeah
just this right attacking b7 group b 8
and I'll take it let's so it's a week
back rank yes counter play with night a
for maybe hmm maybe
that's possible maybe he has some
counter play rook be like rook be eight
we should be seven night a form night a
form but i have worked d7 and rook c7
and then return it and then the sea pawn
really should be good I mean should be
yadete more weakness and strength Luke
his 70s got 95 oops I didn't overlook
that not good news okay but he has no
good way to to prevent drug d7 to c7
anyway
oh I don't know what is he doing here I
wonder what about b3 here and I it's
probably just a drawn hi this is just
the draw at the end
d7 does night c5 unfortunately I be
three that's Knight c3 for that's not a
drawn no not really okay there's nothing
nothing to greet him
the bishop is controlling the night
quite quite reliably but it's not easy
to see how I can can make something
happen here can try to can walk the King
up
you know still but FM if i get if i get
to see three it gets it gets serious yes
93 though this irritates me this kind of
returning the pawn time warning
and I can maybe just play 93 somehow and
then activate with Ruby to may bikini
towards that I don't know I wanted to
play a quick move sure the rooks doing
let's just gained the space yeah maybeee
six year as an option takes bishop g6
with a check I just wanted two to go
here I seem okay let's do that check
you two check check check check I can
take you no no for heaven's sake yeah
okay this is the way to deuce this game
not not many ways but this way like also
more things on time I just I wanted to
resign us now yeah of course it's just a
dead raw cookie five or whatever but
everything drawers for basics of course
I should win it yeah this is just just
clearly better for white and maybe
should have just gone King bee to
instead of this you form but I wanted to
play quickly i hopes yeah i have i also
have totally underestimated this rookie
to counter play it's still very good for
what you six however it's not a good
idea we should be for first yeah you
need to still be precise against the sea
porn that the computer is on plus two is
not helping much it's not helping much
the problem with a success that he
immediately gets the counter playa nicho
computer wants to do something like this
first pushing the rook to d1 and then I
really don't know then then a three
Kingi to later f5
yeah well I'm just better this is not
not not a surprise it all the way here
white was clearly better via chance is
to play 93 which he never did and after
this chances has passed white white is
so just in command here there's also
this very strong yeah stupid I really
played a Jenner a stupid fashion check
check yeah they're all here it's a draw
really and it was until I hit until I
had until I'm all slipped the rook on d5
ruka rookie 5 was what I wanted to do
and oh that's rook be to actually this
is not to draw yeah okay and then I need
to give the check here whatever it's a
in the normal time control it's just a
draw okay thanks for watching